Skylar Tibbits: We focus on
designing physical components
that can build themselves.
So, this project proposes that
you can have self-assembly
at very large scales
This is interesting for
construction scenarios
where it's hard to get to,
it's dangerous
there is extreme environments
it's hard to get
people or machines
or where it's difficult
to build things
in space, under water, etc...
that we could potentially
deposit materials
and they could come together to
build highly functional things.
In this case it's a
ten-by-ten-by-ten space frame.
When the helium dies you're left
with a large rigid structure.
The other category of
research we look at is
How to program
physical materials
to change shape and
property on demand.
On the top left is our
materials and geometry.
That's the obvious stuff.
Everything we know in
the physical world
is made out of materials
and geometry.
Each one of those though
responds to
different types of energy.
If you have moisture, you
might want to use wood.
If you have metal, you might
want to use heat to activate it.
And the way that we
design the geometry
and how those materials
come together
creates mechanical
transformation and
allows us to control how it
folds, curls, bends or twists.
And we've released three
materials so far.
The first one is
programmable carbon fiber
textiles, and wood.
With wood there's a long
history of using wood
as an active building material.
From Japanese joinery
that would use moisture
to make more precise tight
joints to contemporary examples.
But there's two main problems.
One of the problems is that
there's a lot of energy
that goes into forcing plywood
to form into arbitrary shapes.
You have to force it and
steam it and have molds.
The other is that
you are constrained by
the grain direction
that you can find in the forest.
So, we print wood,
we actually deposit wood
we chop it up into a pulp with
sawdust and adhesive or plastics
we're able to print
different grain directions.
Two-dimensional patterns,
three-dimensional patterns
that allow it to
fold, curl, twist and
go from any one arbitrary shape
into any other arbitrary shape.
So, we believe that today we
program computers and machines
and tomorrow we'll
program matter itself.
Thank you.
( applause )